how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
all things mcu
and it's another new day which means
another new
spider-man 3 report slash leak and today
is a really really big one everything
is really coming together now for
spider-man 3 and what has been expected
this whole entire time
the spider-verse and at this point in
time it's pretty much
99 confirmed that spider-man 3 is going
to be a spider-verse film now the focus
is still going to remain on tom holland
don't worry about that i know a lot of
people are worried right now because so
many different characters are going to
be in this movie but the main focus
still will be on tom holland
but having said that one of the most
exciting parts of the entire film that
we're going to get
is seeing toby maguire return and suit
up again
as spider-man and not just toby but a
bunch of other people
are now said to be confirmed for the
movie as well and we're going to break
down everything in this video
don't forget to subscribe if you're new
so you can stay up to date on all the
latest mcu news and to enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a zombie
mysterio funko pop i'm picking a winner
tomorrow and thank you to heroes
hideout.com for providing the funko pop
if you guys are looking for some awesome
funkos be sure to check them out
so last night some major news dropped
toby mcguire was spotted in la going to
a costume
fitting a fitting that is widely
believed to be for spider-man 3.
and this fitting actually came on the
very same day in which we got reports
that toby maguire is pretty much all but
confirmed to come back for spider-man 3.
yesterday collider confirmed that andrew
garfield
will be back in spider-man 3 as his
version of spider-man
kirsten dunst will be back as mj
they said they expect emma stone to
return as well and
marvel and sony are very close to
closing the deal
with toby maguire as spider-man this
means that he is definitely going to
return marvel and sony will work out a
deal for toby maguire to return
in spider-man 3. everybody else is
already on board there's no way they're
not going to have tobey maguire
and again yesterday is when we got this
report and on the same day
yesterday is when we got these photos so
we have confirmation that marvel and
sony are working out a deal with toby
maguire and then on that same day he
goes and gets fitted for a costume
presumably a spider-man costume so at
this point it's pretty much official
that toby maguire is going to be
returning a spider-man from the sam
raimi universe and
andrew garfield is going to be returning
as spider-man from the amazing
spider-man universe now it's also pretty
cool and interesting that we're not only
going to be getting the spider-man from
the different
universes but some of their villains and
their love interests as well
as i mentioned kirsten dunce's mj is
already confirmed to be in spider-man 3.
it was also announced that alfred molina
is officially returning in spider-man 3
as
doc octopus and then of course jay jonah
jameson is already in the mc we saw him
at the end of spider-man far from home
and it is very apparent that this is
indeed the same
jay jonah jameson from the sam raimi
universe so that means that marvel
actually teased the next spider-man
being a multiverse film in the very
last scene the post-credits scene of
spider-man far from home and then we
have andrew garfield returning but not
just andrew garfield
jamie foxx's electro as well and as
collider said they expect
emma stone to return as gwen stacy as
well now one of the things that is very
peculiar about some of these characters
returning
is some of them have actually already
died dr octopus died in the same reimu
universe
it looked like elektro died in the
amazing spider-man 2.
i guess there is a way to say that he
didn't die but gwen stacy
absolutely died in the amazing
spider-man 2. so this is going to be
more than just
opening portals to other universes time
travel could be involved as well whether
that's opening a portal to
a universe at a different time or doctor
strange working his mystical arts powers
or using the time stone to go back in
time
regardless of what happens spider-man 3
is going to be a very
crazy and insanely awesome ride with
tobey maguire
andrew garfield kirsten dunst and
possibly emma stone returning along with
electro
doctor octopus and doctor strange and
let's not forget the report of
daredevil being in spider-man 3 that we
got yesterday this movie is going to be
absolutely insane and i think
a lot of spider-man fans are going to
fall in love with it but let me know
what you think about it in the comments
down below what do you think about toby
mcguire returning andrew garfield
returning and the rest of the cast from
these previous universes returning as
well
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to spider-man 3 and
all things mcu for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof